Everyone loves looking at pictures. But what do you do when pictures aren't
enough? How can you really relive a memory from your past? Well, now, there's
Sniff Book. You see, our olfactory sensory neurons can do amazing things. And
sometimes, a single whiff of a long forgotten smell is enough to take you back
to where you'd experienced that smell before. You might ask, how can Sniff Book
make me remember these times in my life. Well, when a particle enters your
nose. Chemical energy gets transduced to neural energy. The neural impulses has
travel directly to the olfactory bulbs in the temporal lobes. And some of the
nerve fibers of the olfactory bulb go directly to the amygdala. It is here that
the magic happens. The amygdala is involved in emotion. And this is one reason
why smells can sometimes bring back such clear, strong emotions. The Sniff Book
is available for three easy payments of $9.99, so order your Sniff Book today
because the past is just a sniff away.